nicolas dupont aignan est venu chasser
sur les terres de jean frédéric poisson
en meeting à rambouillet il a voulu
rassembler ses militants yvelinois et
attirer de nouveaux adhérents à son
mouvement debout la france est un parti
qui progresse dans les yvelines aux
élections régionales nous avons fait un
gros score puisque j'ai la liste que je
conduisais a fait près de 6 et demi pour
cent au niveau régional et un bon score
dans les yvelines
donc nous progressons la venue d'un
candidat à la présidentielle à
rambouillet a attiré des curieux
ainsi que des militants de longue date
rallier à la cause de son parti en tant
que citoyen française chaussade naturel
de s'intéresser aux différents
présidentiable et à partir de là c'était
important pour moi de rencontrer une des
personnes qui s'y présente dont nicolas
dupont aignan je suis pas forcément
convaincu par ce que il a bien préparé
son programme
sauf que pour moi j'ai quand même le
sentiment que le fait qu'il ait pas été
ministre qui n'est pas exercer des
activités à la tête de l'état c'est
quand même un mandant un handicap
sa lucidité ça m'a toujours épaté son
bon sens
son honnêteté présent au meeting de
nicolas dupont aignan philippe brillault
il a récemment démissionné de son poste
de conseiller départemental et se
retrouve dans certaines propositions du
candidat
aujourd'hui si je viens d'écouter ce
n'est pas pour autant que je suis là
pour adhérer je suis là pour écouter et
pour l'encourager
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait beaucoup
de bonnes idées qui était partagée par
beaucoup
voilà je
que c'est intéressant d'écouter tout le
monde prochaine étape pour nicolas
dupont aignan rassemblé 500 parrainages
d'élus locaux ou nationaux avant la date
butoir fixée courant mars 2017